the world keeps changing so in a big
part of what I focus on at any given
time is you know making sure we are
innovating and building products for the
future you know it's just got to be a
normal course of how you think and so
you know we are constantly thinking
about what to do next so you know
Android is very popular people are using
smartphones but you know I always didn't
think about what is the next version of
how people use computing right and so we
are thinking about you know things like
virtual reality or augmented reality so
these are all new areas but we are
constantly thinking about it and so you
have to do that on a constant basis to
push forward the thing which attracted
me to Google and to Internet in general
is that it's a great equalizer right and
so to me always being struck by the fact
that Google search worked the same
mm-hmm if as long as you had access to
computer with connectivity if you were a
rural kid anywhere
or if you were a professor at Stanford
or hard work and and to me you know I
want Google to strive to push to do that
not just build technology for a certain
segments right for me it's it matters
that you know we drive technology as an
equalizing force as an enabler to
everyone around the world
you just watch - amazing clips with
sundar Pichai take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]